welcome back well the interviews they're
over at the White House and a shortlist
of three people were being told remain
as potential Supreme Court picks by
President Trump he's set to announce the
final decision at 9:00 p.m. Eastern this
upcoming Monday night and Democrats of
course are doing everything in their
power to whip up their base no matter
who the choice is the writ choice is the
resistance it must continue joining us
now with the latest is Fox News
correspondent Kristen Fisher Kristen
good evening AP well president Trump
told reporters on board Air Force One
tonight that his shortlist has shrunk to
four and he thinks that he's narrowed it
down to two or three finalists now our
sources tell Fox News that those
finalists are three appellate court
judges all of whom are widely regarded
to be constitutional conservatives they
are Brett Kavanaugh from the DC Circuit
the Sixth Circuit's Raymond Catholic and
Amy Coney Barrett of the Seventh Circuit
now Cavanaugh is kind of the steady
Washington insider the 53 year old sits
on the same powerful Court that served
as a stepping stone for three current
Supreme Court justices as well as the
late Antonin Scalia he clerked for
retiring Justice Kennedy and he has deep
ties to his former boss president george
w bush another former kennedy clerk
judge Raymond Catholic the 51 year old
is known for being a bit of a loner he's
less high-profile and has less of a
judicial record than Cavanaugh but he's
also a lot less controversial which
could help him get confirmed help him
get through the Senate and then there's
a me koni Barrett the only female
finalist we believe she has seven
children she clerked for the late
Justice Antonin Scalia and she's a
devout Catholic but her writings on
overturning judicial precedent have
raised a red flag with a very critical
Republican senator Susan Collins who
fears that she might overturn roe v wade
now President Trump says he hopes to
make his decision by Sunday then on
Monday a big primetime announcement at
the White House something he made
official during that rally tonight in
Montana listen here if you turn in
Monday at nine o'clock I think you're
going to be extremely happy
I want to thank Justice Kennedy for his
lifetime of truly distinguished service
and he had confidence in me he left
because he said you're gonna pick
somebody great but Democrats say no one
on the president shortlist is great they
are now putting the pressure on two key
Republican senators lisa murkowski and
susan collins one liberal group is
planning to spend millions millions of
dollars on advertising and activism in
the Senators home states Alaska and
Maine which is the exact same strategy
that they used to help defeat the
Republican effort to repeal Obamacare
last year but of course Pete this is
going to be a much more difficult fight
for the Democrats to win you're right
so precedent there Kristen thank you
very much appreciate it as we mentioned
Democrats the throw in the kitchen sink
hit president Trump Supreme Court
candidates none more than at Judge Amy
Coney Barrett you can't put it any other
way an incredibly qualified US Court of
Appeals judge who is a devout Catholic
and a mother of seven children the left
hypocrisy on her is so thick you could
choke on it joining us now with reaction
is Kerry Severino policy director of the
Conservative judicial crisis Network and
a former clerk for Justice Clarence
Thomas along with attorney and radio
talk show host Leo Terrell thank you
both for joining us this morning Kerry
let me start with you so the criticism
of Amy Barrett and knowing how
accomplished she is is that well she may
be just too devout of a Catholic yet the
left has you know usually sees a
qualified female candidate and
especially someone who's already been
confirmed with 55 votes as someone who
would be yet again breaking the glass
ceiling why the resistance to Amy well
this is really ridiculous because under
our Constitution there is no religious
test for office and that's what they're
trying to do here what I think is
happening is you're seeing people like a
senator Feinstein who are very
threatened by an accomplished articulate
but conservative woman because that
really puts the lie to their identity
politics that she's does not toe their
line and their feminist idea of what a
woman should be and she understands how
to defend her positions so I think
that's someone they feel very threatened
by and that's why we saw the hard attack
on her during her confirmation hearings
with that famous of it's so strange line
the dogma lives loudly within her store
you know that'll go down in history and
now it might go down in history as the
beginning of a Supreme Court justices
career well yet she was still confirmed
with 55 votes leo and before I go to you
we're gonna let Amy Coney Barrett speak
for herself she talked to spoke to a
group in Jacksonville Florida this is
what she said about interpreting the
Constitution listen say I want to
appoint someone who's pro-life or I want
to appoint someone whose primary focus
is protecting minority rights though the
candidates are talking to their bases
and talking to the electorate and saying
signal I'm gonna put people on the court
who share your policy preferences as I
was saying before I think that's not the
right qualification for a justice I mean
we shouldn't be putting people on the
court that share our policy preferences
we should be putting people on the court
who want to apply the Constitution
applying the Constitution Leo what what
do you take issue with there we
shouldn't put people on there who adopt
or believe in the same policy let me
tell you have you read about this woman
I've read her before I came on your show
this woman does not believe in story
decisis Carey you know what that means
she doesn't believe in established law
she is telling people they look very bad
no excuse me with all due respect I
don't think Roe versus Wade
is a bad law it's been on the books for
about 45 years but this if you want to
be honest she is talking about over
attorney established law that scares me
as a lawyer and Kari you didn't mention
that
she also said in a speech that lawyers
should have a high higher calling to God
God has nothing to do with the law this
woman is scary very scary because she's
a threat to over attorney established
law Kari and Pete Pete I hope you talk
about those items
that's dangerous well you read as I'm
sure many you did like many Americans
looking at the Declaration of
Independence yesterday of course our
founders believed in God believed in
nature's God and we've there's been you
would acknowledge
Leo there been plenty of laws in this
country that were on the books for 45
years that should have never been
the books in the first place so take roe
v wade as an example carry you know
there there are a lot of folks who look
at yours prudence on the left and the
right and say that the right found there
in roe v wade it really they really had
to bend over backwards to find that that
right to privacy within the constitution
of believe it was penumbra's formed by
emanations on roe v-- wade carry can you
honor the constitution without being
ideological absolutely and that's what
ami coney Barrett was talking about it's
not about finding someone who's gonna
give you a laundry list of preferences
you want achieved every justice on the
Supreme Court agrees that there are
times when you have to overturn a law
that were ruling that was incorrectly
decided if we didn't have that we would
still have the horrible Dred Scott case
here finding that that's a red herring
let me just ask you point blank hey
ready okay roe v-- wade tell me right
now on national television bad decision
tell me right now tell all the
pro-choice Republicans Madhuri pot and
say go ahead I'll let you answer
yourself Lawrence Drive President
Obama's legal adviser a Harvard Law
Professor constitutional law at George
MacArthur he thinks it is not it is not
a law that a president that is a good
quality president that but the the
question here is very different I don't
think this justice is going to be of the
vote to overturn Roe vs. Wade because
this middle justice the swing vote is
now justice Chief Justice John Roberts I
think he is much harder to predict and I
have no idea what he will do in this
case there's a lot of people in this
country might repeat roe v wade is
terrible and abortion is a sin on this
country that's there's a lot of people
that legitimately hold that policy view
there's also a lot of people including
my professor at Princeton University
Robby George who could who pointed out
many times that the decision of roe v
wade whether you're pro-life or
pro-choice was was judicial activism at
its finest respectfully when we carry we
carry we carry euzeth Dred Scott as an
analogy she insults the intelligence of
every viewer now you know why since 1973
or all the current administration
the legislation has that knowledge has a
knowledge roe v-- wade and this judge is
hell-bent on overturning roe v-- wade
she should not be nominated no you're
making it a single issue I think the
First Amendment the Second Amendment
religiously big issue government
overreach issues of course it's a big
issue and it's one of the things that
could come before the court are you
saying it's not a legitimate policy
position to believe that maybe it could
be decided at the state level yeah that
this this judge should believe in it
story decisis don't you believe that
Carrie can you just say yesterday no
absolutely believe darkness Isis but
nobody started sighs didn't say that
every case once decided never gets
overturned no zero justices in the
Supreme Court believed that this is all
a distraction these are scare tactics
used against justice O'Connor Justice
Kennedy justice Souter they were saying
they would be the vote to overturn Roe
versus Wade those were the three votes
that upheld over his wade in the Planned
Parenthood case it's a distraction from
the real principles we're talking about
here which is is this someone who's
going to look at the law for first and
foremost look at the Constitution for
speeches and she said I didn't
understand this as a lawyer she told a
group of lawyers that we as lawyers have
a higher calling to God religion I think
our framers make written that and she
has said specifically if her moral
beliefs conflicted with her role as a
judge she says she would recuse herself
what else can you ask she says
specifically I'm not doing this
substitute but I think this is the law
comes first indicative of the fact these
are gonna be some confirmation hearings
no matter who's chosen that'll be
must-see TV a good debate Kerry Leo
thank you for time today tonight